we now look at an example similar to the
previous one in which we have again two
scenarios but in which we have both
discrete and continuous random variables
involved you have one dollar and the
opportunity to play in a lottery with
probability 1/2 you do nothing and
you're left with the dollar that you
started with with probability 1/2 you
decide to play the lottery and in that
case you get back an amount of money
which is random and uniformly
distributed between 0 & 2
is the random variable X discrete the
answer is no because it takes values on
a continuous range is the random
variable X continuous the answer is no
because the probability that X takes the
value of exactly one is equal to 1/2
even though X takes values in a
continuous range this is not enough to
make it a continuous random variable we
defined continuous random variables to
be those that can be described by a PDF
and we have seen that in such a case any
individual point should have zero
probability but this is not the case
here and so X is not continuous we call
X a mixed random variable more generally
we can have a situation where the random
variable X with some probability is the
same as a particular discrete random
variable and with some other probability
it is equal to some other continuous
random variable such a random variable X
does not have a PMF because it is not
discrete also it does not have a PDF
because it is not continuous how do we
describe such a random variable well we
can describe it in terms of a cumulative
distribution function CDF are always
well defined for all kinds of random
variables we have two scenarios and so
we can use the total
probability theorem and write that the
CDF is equal to the probability of the
first scenario which is P times the
probability that the random variable Y
is less than or equal to X this is a
conditional model under the first
scenario and with some probability we
have the second scenario and under that
scenario X will take a value less than
little X if and only if the our random
variable Z will take a value less than
little X or in CDF notation this is P
times the CDF of the random variable Y
evaluated at this particular X plus
another weighted term involving the CDF
of the random variable Z we can also
define the expected value of x in a way
that is consistent with the total
expectation theorem namely
define the expected value of x to be the
probability of the first scenario in
which case x is discrete times the
expected value of the Associated
discrete random variable plus the
probability of the second scenario under
which X is continuous times the expected
value of the Associated continuous
random variable going back to our
original example we have two scenarios
the scenarios that we can call a 1 and a
2 under the first scenario we have a
uniform PDF and the corresponding CDF is
as follows it's flat until 0 then it
rises linearly and then it stays flat
and the value here is equal to 1 so the
slope here is 1/2 so the slope is equal
to the corresponding PDF under the
second scenario we have a discrete
actually a constant random variable and
so the CDF
is flat at zero until this value and the
dot value have a jump equal to one we
then use the total probability theorem
which tells us that the CDF of the mixed
random variable will be one half times
the CDF under the first scenario plus
1/2 times the CDF under the second
scenario so we take one half of this
plot and one half of that plot and add
them up what we get is the function that
rises now at the slope of 1/4 then we
have a jump and the size of that jump is
going to be equal to 1/2 and then it
continues at the slope of 1/4 until it
reaches this value and after that time
it remains flat so this is a simple
illustration that for mixed random
variables it's not too hard to obtain
the corresponding CDF even though this
random variable does not have a PDF or a
PMF of its own